hi there steve kaufman here well i'm
about to take off on my trip to
israel and crete uh first i'll go to
london i'll be in london uh basically on
the 17th
and 18th
uh but i won't have much time there i'll
be visiting with my son and his family
then we fly to tel aviv i'll be there
for nine days
i would love to have a meet-up if anyone
is interested in meeting up
around let's say the 24th
of um october in tel aviv please uh let
me know here
uh then i'll be in crete from the i
guess it's the 28th or so of october
till about the 7th of november
and then i come back and i'll be largely
in a lat the last you know from the say
the 8th to the 15th or so so if there's
any chance of meeting up please let me
know we can try and arrange it
travel and languages all right i mean
it's so exciting now for me
uh having spent a lot of effort now and
and even you know even the amount that i
have put into greek so far is a form of
travel i'm listening to podcasts reading
the transcripts of podcasts about the
history of greece i'm beginning to
discover greece
reading about greece in greek reading
greek letters it almost gives me a giddy
feeling
i now want to not only visit crete i
want to go to athens and see the
parthenon again i visited there in the
70s
uh
language learning is a part of
discovering the world and it gets us
traveling it's intimately connected with
travel
i did start on the hebrew but i just
found that i couldn't do both languages
and uh
i figured i had a better chance of
getting a toehold on greek
simply because of the the writing system
in hebrew i found it a bit difficult
with letters having you know different
potential pronunciations no vowels and
stuff like that i am sure that when i'm
in
israel i'll get motivated again to work
on my hebrew i'll probably work on my
hebrew while i'm in israel
and and as i say next year is is my year
to get after
uh the middle east uh you know that
whole that part of the world which will
include hebrew and arabic and farsi and
turkish i want to do that now i've been
told that that farsi gets you sort of
edging towards hindi so you know further
in the future i want to get at those
languages so all of this is learning
languages is a form of travel it's a
form of discovery it's a form of
exploration
it just provides here i am i'm going to
be 72 on the 8th of october
and i'm just exploring like i never had
a chance to do while i was busy working
for most of my professional career so uh
just to update you on my travel plans
and my longer term language learning
plans
thanks for listening
bye for now
[Music]
you